[Music]
no one knew
how big chess could become moving over
here is the correct choice i think right
no i can't because he's pinned it by the
king wait did he just say pinned
he said he said he actually said pinned
oh my gosh he's actually learning the
terminology i don't believe this
no one believed it could succeed no i i
can't watch pogchamps this is this is a
chess channel
i only do chess here chess broke all the
rules of twitch
but it succeeded anyway yes it's going
to come down to the wire
but now king oh my god oh my god
[Music]
no please don't and it's too soon
it's too soon hikaru we didn't even
reach a climax
against all odds chess made it on twitch
and it's here to stay
so in case you haven't been near a
computer for the past year
chess kind of blew up in 2020 and if
that sounds insane to you
that's because it is chess isn't as
visually engaging as some of the top
games on the platform like
valorant league of legends hell even
rust
but with many people forced indoors due
to the kovan 19 pandemic
the game saw a massive rise in
popularity
all over the world people needed to kill
time streams
exploded in viewership it makes sense
but why was everybody playing chess
no i didn't see that
now if you want a game to succeed on
twitch you need the biggest names to
play it
over the last year we've seen tons of
games come and go
thanks to streaming superstars sea of
thieves
fall guys among us there are dozens of
fad games on twitch from just the last
year alone somehow chess
survived people are still playing before
the initial boom
no one on twitch really gave a [ __ ]
about chess sure there were live stream
tournaments but
no one was really watching and then in
october of 2020
something weird happened netflix's chess
drama the queen's gambit
quickly became one of the most viewed
shows of the year
helping introduce the game to an
entirely new audience nobody would have
predicted that it would have been
a freaking global pandemic
the biggest streamer on twitch or one of
them xqc at the time
super gm's getting into twitch so many
things together happen and then later
the number one show on netflix being a
chess show
streamers were trying chess for the
first time and most of the chess
community recognized that it was great
for the game
it's very obvious that it is growing
the overall appeal of chess that's what
popular culture
in generally tends to do on top of that
it makes chess a lot more
accessible and i think people who may
have been intimidated to start
playing or start watching before are now
getting their toes wet he has to block
with this
i take it's game over he can't take me
back nice he gave me the game
good game all of a sudden chess was huge
on twitch but long time content creators
like hikaru and the botes sisters
quickly realized that their time to
shine
might be limited remember most twitch
games
are fads it seemed pretty likely that
without something huge
chess streams would vanish like the
hundreds before it
these creators knew they had to do
something
and they had to do it fast
no please don't and it's too soon
it's too soon hikaru we didn't even
reach a climax
[Music]
and nem is the one who has to constantly
make this decision do i take the bishop
on f4
and when you're only starting chess it's
it takes a lot of time to make these
decisions and you pointed this out
robert
10 minutes might seem like a lot but for
these players they're not that
experienced that time evaporates
really really quickly and already seven
and a half minutes seven moves in
seven seconds move charlie oh gosh
he's gonna lose on time he's just not
seeing his clock three seconds oh my god
dirty flag this will be the first dirty
flag in the tournament
and we get to witness it two seconds one
second
no flag oh my god i can't believe i just
did that
oh yucky
pog champs was the chess community shot
at keeping the game
relevant on twitch 16 streamers with
coaching and commentary well i mean i
think more than that for me it's not
it's not so much about guessing it's the
fact that
oh oh
here comes the owl oh
it was a huge success with an average of
over a hundred thousand viewers
throughout the event
fans came in droves to watch their
favorite streamers compete in a game
that
for many of them was way out of their
comfort zone oh no
okay whoa but you can take the pawn oh
my gosh what's going on now queen g2
check is coming in pawn to each two also
oh my god checkmate checkmate
queen g2
oh my god
[Music]
pogchamps broke records as 140 000
people follow chess.com's twitch channel
throughout the event
and the chess category as a whole hit a
hundred and fifty thousand peak viewers
former league of legends pro voyboy took
home the event with the lion's share of
the 50
000 prize pool going to the charity of
his choice
and you could see just how much fun the
event was for
everyone involved and um yeah it's been
nothing but fun nothing but love it's
been super
awesome to to get back into the chess
again and kind of reignite a passion
that
was basically dormant since i was a kid
but chess's rise as a form of
entertainment for the masses
wasn't thrilling for everyone in fact
some chess players
saw pogchamps as a joke no i can't watch
pogchamps this is this is a chess
channel
i only do chess here i don't stream
other games just chess
but thanks for asking if you want to
watch nonsense you're welcome to watch
nonsense i'm not going to stop you
these staunch traditionalists seemingly
couldn't understand that the game's
sudden popularity on twitch might
actually be a good thing
high-level players were caught in the
crossfire and they were told that they
were essentially wasting their time
teaching new players the game so in in
terms like the opening you know what you
want to do you want to start with d4
let's say i play d5 here just a sort of
like repetition to get to the
get out of the opening phase
and here i can kind of do whatever
yeah i mean it doesn't really matter the
order just you know you're gonna move
the knife
depending on what they think right and
sure it may not be the high level
strategic play that many people are used
to
but for the average viewer low level
chess is just easier to understand
chess was becoming more and more
approachable to those on the outside
looking
in and pog champs was a huge
part of that but you have to understand
to some of these professional players
chess isn't just a game it's this thing
that they've dedicated their entire
lives to and it kind of felt like some
of these big streamers
or making a mockery of it if i look at
xqc
i'll tell you what what the reaction is
the the classic like the classic chess
world what they'll say is oh this guy's
no good at chess he's so bad why do we
waste our time like
he's just no good at this game so he's
no good at this game he's nobody which
is absolute rubbish obviously because
as we all know um xuc first of all i
mean without talking about him as a
streamer
he was he he was a grand master at
overwatch which i'm sorry but if you if
you put me
playing overwatch for i don't care how
long or you put magnus
playing overwatch i'm sorry we would we
would be total noobs like
that just that's just a fact but you
have to imagine that the people who have
these complaints have been playing chess
as they were three or four years old and
it's been their entire
life's career to them it is more than
just entertainment it's an art it's
sport it's a game
and it is something that is almost so
holy but before pogchamps
chess wasn't exactly a sport rich in
viewership
if anything these events that showcase
low-level chess
have allowed the game to secure more
sponsorships and funding
for high-level events i mean i think
it's it's very
obvious that the people who are being
entertained by 1 000 level games
and who are learning from it are the
kind of people who would
go way over their head if they're going
to watch um you know like a
feeder tournament or tata steel or
something like that
despite the continued hate that
pogchamps received from parts of the
chess community
it brought massive viewership to twitch
and chess.com knew that they couldn't
waste
any time in planning a sequel and with
pogchamps 2
they wanted to go even bigger once again
16 players
vied for a 50 000 prize pool but this
time
it featured a much more diverse group of
internet celebrities
hell even the mountain from game of
thrones competed
and with additional matches being
streamed more members of the
professional chess community were able
to get involved and join the broadcast
as both coaches and commentators
actually are we missing something better
that
is there basically she can she can
blunder checkmate if she takes it oh my
oh my i have blundered it i don't want
to jinx this i don't want to exist again
no no no no
no no no probably you probably have to
go bishop f4 right after
um h4 and the most recent tournament
pogchamps 3
prove that many of these content
creators aren't just playing chess
because it brings in
viewers at this point they're doing it
because they enjoy the game
and genuinely just want to get better
pogchamps 3 was chess.com's
largest broadcast to date raising more
money for charity than the past
two competitions combined the viewers of
the event helped raise
fifty thousand dollars for various
charities with chess.com donating an
additional hundred thousand
overall like i think this has been a
really great introduction to chess and
i'm excited to like
keep at it you know and i think that's
the important thing that i'm getting out
of this
is like you know i've become interested
in this game
because of this event well at the end of
the day it's like we had fun
um you know it's all going to charity
and hopefully you guys will let me come
back because i'm about to be i'm going
to be on it now
and the competitors really do care
sardoche took home the prize after being
told by
countless professionals that his style
of chess
is just a low-level joke but he
continued to
grind and improve and eventually became
the champion i play six hours of game
every day
just sometimes never get out of my bed
and pay on my phone
uh that was something i really was
focused on so i'm so proud i want it and
i know i will chill a bit i will i will
focus on another thing i could play a
bit of rocket league and stuff like this
but i will never forget chess and play
it's until i get
at least 2 000 sometimes and i mean
who can say i eat 2000 levels some some
day in my life
i think that will be a really good life
goal
due to the massive success of pogchamps
hundreds of thousands of people
now tune in daily to watch their
favorite streamers play this old ass
game
no no no no no he sees it
he sees the bishop can take then he
takes my penis
how often do you see tf blade think wait
i gotta stop doing this [ __ ] oh my god
nobody
i'm never gonna have a student
that's loud you're dumb bro you just
you've talked big time because man i
take the pawn
oh no it's still stupid
trust an o g cause mana o to the g
out here you get me and with chess
blowing up online
many of the players who turned to
content creation
have been embraced by the gaming
community and that's the point i think
until now chess has had a very
intimidating look where people are just
like oh i've never played chess i would
be awful at and it's like well do you
say that about something like i've never
played monopoly i would be
awful at it you just have to learn the
rules and it's not
as stressful as people think it is and i
think it's changing that perception
and often how you perceive some kind of
sport or hobby or game is going to
determine whether you ever try
it and we're addressing that problem at
its core
pawchamp started as just a small event
where streamers who suck at chess could
showcase their low tier gameplay
but it's become so much more than that
pogchamps 3 was the final
view to all the haters who thought it
was just a joke
chess beat all the odds and survived on
twitch
while plenty of other titles continue to
die out after only a few weeks of
popularity
chess isn't a fad it's here to stay
that's what i was trying to do with what
oh sorry i can't talk about it anymore
all right wait he actually played the
bomb cloud
you see that's the trunk you invited me
for for the reason